a Stewart mentioned this is the first
talk in the 2012/2013 savings
sustainable ventureprise series the
talks sponsored by LC Bay the Center for
business environment and will be
broadcast simultaneously through the
Yale livestream Channel so I want to
welcome all of you who are here as well
as those who are watching online to this
speaker series today we're quite pleased
to welcome dr. Richard Sandor
distinguished author and founder of the
Chicago climate exchange in today's talk
Richard will explore how financial
innovation and derivatives can have a
positive impact on areas of global
importance dr. sindoor presents a view
that financial derivatives and
market-based practices can in fact be a
force for good in addressing global
issues particularly with regard to the
environment sanders recognized as a
father of financial futures for his
pioneering work in developing the first
interest rate futures contract in the
1970s while he served as a chief
economist at the Chicago Board of Trade
he's also a founder of the Chicago
climate exchange the world's first
exchange to facilitate the reduction and
trading of all six greenhouse gases in
2007 he was named as the father of
carbon trading by Time magazine for his
work in designing developing and
launching the Chicago climate change
exchange he's currently a lecturer at
the University Chicago Law School and a
distinguished professor of environmental
finance at the School of Management at
picking University please join me in
welcoming dr. Richard Sandor as the
inaugural speaker of the 2012-2013 save
and speaker series
it's a great thrill to be here I think
it's a little too loud it's a great
thrill to be here with all of you today
and Yale is a special place in my heart
for environmental trading I came here
about 12 years ago when carbon trading
was just a dream and I made this
presentation of what I'd like to do when
I grew up and then I came back after we
launched it to kind of give a start of
what we're doing and then I guess it was
2006 I came back at the invitation of an
old friend Gus Speth
to give a progress report so this is the
fourth time I've been in this room and
it's been very fortuitous I want to give
you an update and talk to you today
about good derivatives financial
innovation has taken a pretty bad rap
over the last three or four years as a
Menendez person as Paul Volcker said the
only good financial innovation in the
post-world War two period was the ATM
pretty nasty Joe Stiglitz
Nobel Prize winner and quite a brilliant
economist thought that he couldn't
really come up with any good complex
derivative I want to ask you and why you
know what it why is this happen what
does it mean for all of us and most
importantly is it accurate everybody in
the room know who Henry Ford is yeah
anybody know who Luca Pacioli is he's
not the lead from The Godfather
okay he didn't sleep with fish or
anything like that anybody heard of them
okay I would make the following thesis
Luka makes Henry very very small Luca
Pacioli is the father of accounting okay
and invented a financial innovation why
don't they get any talk why don't they
get interest they tend to be wholesale
they're not consumers okay
they tend to be oftentimes group efforts
like film so it's hard to get into a
tour and they generally in the past have
not been patentable and I want to make
the case that there is a class of good
derivatives and what are good
derivatives they are and first of all
what's a derivative a derivative is a
financial instrument based on another
one I was asked in 1974 what we were
gonna call these things Ginnie Mae
futures Treasury bond futures and I said
they really are like calculus they are
derived from something else and that's
the sense of where the word emanates it
is a meant to be a calculus type of
transformation of one type of financial
instrument into another corn into corn
options securities into stock options
crude oil into futures all of those are
derivatives well what's a good one a
good one is one that's transparent one
centrally cleared serves a price
discovery function what are prices in
the future and sometimes is meant for
making or taking delay
it's economic purpose is to facilitate
risk transfer what's a bad derivative
one that's opaque not centrally cleared
and doesn't serve that purpose let me
give you an example of a bad derivative
Greek debt okay with no offense to
anybody who might be of Greek origin
Greek debt insurance on the Greek
government sold for 27 basis points in
2007 and was not margined since its
founding is a modern republic in 1829
Greek the Greek government has been in -
for default every other year okay and it
was priced at a quarter of a percent
with no margin no price transparency and
defaulted how have these grown and
they've been remarkable when I got
interested in this business in 1970
first time there was thirteen point
seven million contracts last year twenty
two billion compound growth rate of
eighteen percent a year
bigger than Airlines automobiles and
every major industry save tank what
about the size of these exchanges if you
take a look at just the CMA the inter
and the Continental exchange and the
CBOE the market caps in excess of thirty
billion dollars top five Airlines 24
billion just to put it in perspective
the market cap really is just as
economists know the cost of replacing
something it's not its economic value so
what is the the economic value
how does it get translated well clearly
one is hedging and everybody from canes
to Lester tells her argued about what
they might be and nobody really is
certain but the word backwardation was
Keynes's word to describe the insurance
cost of a futures contract in addition
to that we have price discovery the
price discovery is not transparency what
I mean by price discovery is a farmer
looks up at the the quotations sees
soybean prices See's corn prices and
makes a judgment which to plant so he's
in the fall when it comes to the fall
he's able to make or she is able to make
a decision without even touching the
market the other so we have hedging we
have price discovery as a result of
these markets the wholesale to retail
spread what we call the bid-ask spread
has been crushed in markets that do it
so they have an overflow value of
transparency the kinds of people that
use the risk transfer market are called
hedgers the kinds of people who
undertake or underwrite the risk are
called speculators speculate it's a real
bad name right but we have to
distinguish between speculation and
gambling in gambling the risk is created
there's no risk in Las Vegas or Macau
until you build the casino soybean
prices go up and down as to interest
rates well before you build the inning
and exchange and it's very important to
distinguish it in as a matter of fact
the evil words of speculation don't seem
to apply to Steven jobs who basically
found speculative capital called venture
got rid of his financial risk was happy
to assume the technology risk and he
gave it to a speculator so private
equity other kinds of capital formation
exists all the time with speculative
capital it got so bad in France in the
30s during the Spanish Civil War
Franco was having enormous problems food
prices were going up he didn't know what
to do so what he did was call in all of
the speculators into Madrid for a
meeting and he stopped the high food
prices he murdered all of them and sure
enough it had its effect grain prices
fell inventories were depleted but what
happened was the very next year there
was a short crop and drought in Chu
ensued and you had no buffer stocks and
no carryovers and speculation plays that
role of inventory of things what are
some of the applications of good
derivatives clearly we've gone from 25%
of disposable income on food down to 10%
since 50 we're going through a major
drought in the United States soybeans
corn at record levels yet it all gets to
where it's supposed to be it will get
harvested efficiently nobody rails about
it even in today's world if we take a
look at mortgages when we started Ginnie
Mae futures the bid-ask spread was
three-quarters of a point a point
bid-ask between the mortgage and the
sale of it into a package security it
shrunk to 1/32 the present value of that
is $6,000 for every homeowner in the
United States as a result of the
transparency that the market brought if
we take a look at jet fuel
so we've got housing we've got food how
about transportation Southwest Airways
survived by hedging its fuel costs while
American and United went out of business
and were and became bankrupt how about
banks in 2007 and 2008 we had the
biggest calamity that we have had in the
world since the depression not one bank
failed because of interest rate risk its
major input and output and there was no
failures too due to lack of interest
rate risk management in contrast to the
decade of the 80s where we lost 5,000
SNL's
and 15 or 20,000 banks let's talk about
10-year debt now government financing
not only banks and banking and risk
management this spread when we wrote the
10-year note futures contract the
bid-ask spread was an eighth to a
quarter of a point it now trades in
sixty fourths the savings to the US
government as a result of this
transparency and the narrowing of
spreads is somewhere between two hundred
and fifty to five hundred million
dollars last year depending on what you
the way you measure it but it's likely
1/2 of bed you're five hundred million
the transaction costs in the secondary
market the savings are six to ten
billion that goes for pension ears etc
and anybody's looking for a PhD thesis
topic there is no work on this in the
academic world about the narrowing of
spreads and the economic benefit of
reduced transaction costs associated
with organize more it's none that I know
of in major there's a tries at it but
nobody's really written a book on the
value of these markets the last thing
and I'll get to because of the audience
of a good derivative is essentially the
first use of cap-and-trade to deal with
acid rain in the 1980s Michael Douglas
made a movie called black rain you know
it was a metaphor for everything evil we
had 18 million tons into the atmosphere
it was concentrated Congress passed the
law the Clean Air Act of 1990 in of the
7 800 pages there's 15 pages and that's
all you needed to build cap-and-trade
into the legislation we worked on it a
number of other people did but it was a
wide skin scale use cap-and-trade for
those of you who are not familiar with
it essentially you can deal with it an
environmental problem by command and
control just mandating everybody reduced
by 10 percent or we actually mandate
actual fixes or you can say everybody
has to lower it by 10 percent and if
you're particularly good at this and I'm
not so good you can fuel switch from
high sulfur to low sulfur coal I can't
my boilers won't allow that I've got to
go through a technology fix and build a
scrubber I can buy the excess reductions
and hedge myself while I'm installing
the technology this program is down to 3
million tons 3 million from 18 million
the annual savings in healthcare costs
last year were a hundred and twenty
three billion dollars and the cost of
the program was 1.3 and every year 30 to
40 thousand 30
the 40,000 people lived that would have
died if you had the emissions in the 80s
the most successful program that I know
about it and it was rewarded in
Washington DC by scrapping the program
but we'll get to that in the question
and answer period this you know was my
first experience with it we ultimately
had auctions at the border trade in a
fifth grade class actually decided the
best way to deal with acid rain was to
buy permits allowances rights to emit
and retire them the teacher taught the
class about cap and trade by handing out
chewing-gum rights and if you didn't
chew your gum you could sell it to
somebody else and that's how the kids
learn this very complex program called
cap and trade it's just the use right
that you give out less and less and it
works very very well in about 1995 I got
interested pre Kyoto a work with a man
by the name of Maurice strong to try to
get a voluntary program because we
didn't think Kyoto would get off the
ground
eventually it did and we set up this
voluntary exchange in the United States
everybody said nobody will join an
exchange without law okay nobody would
join without man Dacian by the federal
government and you could never get
anybody to volunteer and cut their
emissions and do it on a legally binding
contractual basis we got 450 members we
got IBM DuPont Intel Ford Honeywell
etcetera hundred and ten companies 700
million tons why did they join
for joined because they saw it as a
competitive weapon if they got started
no three here they could deal with
having a carbon account in Marseilles
and Stuttgart and places like that
AEP the largest coal-fired utility
joined get an expression in Chicago and
they wanted to be involved in any
perspective legislation that was their
motive the expression around the
exchange was if you're not at the table
then you're on the menu okay and so it's
good reason to be at the table
Baxter joined just because they said
there's a health care issue and how can
we be a sustainable company and not deal
with the environment
DuPont joined because they could find a
way to make refrigerants without HFCS
and could make a ton of money by
changing the manufacturing process how'd
they do they cut in the pilot program
from oh three to ten they cut emissions
by four hundred million tons more than
France they also dealt with 53 million
tons of offset 11 million tons that
arose from better forestry management so
they cut totally or offset 469 different
areas most importantly they sent price
signals and everybody said and it's a
very important lesson you can't possibly
get people to change behavior with a
dollar or two carbon there's a guy by
the name of Isaac Berzin who developed a
process to turn algae into jet fuel he's
a professor at MIT and he thought he
could cut tonnage by a hundred million
tons a year and a dollar
would give him a hundred million a year
in profit and he raised ten million
dollars and is now listed as one of the
most important inventors and $1 Karpin
did that we put together a rural program
in India big problem in India is animal
waste so you can take micro digesters
shovel animal waste into these
containers the methane rises to the top
you run a copper tube into a house and
as a result of that the family can cook
with the gas the young girls don't have
to go in forage would a spillover social
benefit there's less lung disease and
they made on a dollar carbon the average
family made $20 a year you may not think
that's a lot but when it's a dollar a
day that's an awful lot we started with
3000 families we got up to 15,000 50,000
and when we sold the exchange we had a
hundred thousand world poor in a program
that eliminated methane and stopped it
from going into the air and live better
as a result of it
so there's a widespread application here
and let me talk about some final
thoughts and where I think things are
going what are the next major accidents
here US has at fifteen and a half
trillion dollar economy fifteen and a
half trillion anybody want to guess at
what the entire policy surplus for the
insurance companies are for given
hurricanes earthquakes tornadoes loss of
life it's five hundred fifty million
dollars
one event could take it out and it's the
same issue of risk-based capital and if
we got together at Yale two gentlemen
and I and all of you what's a good
strategy for us for to make a ton of
money go to Florida or go to the San
Andreas Fault and just walk it and then
write insurance every step of the way I
think the biggest risk you can and if it
goes wrong you have a free putt to the
state of California because nobody's
gonna let homeowners go under so this
free put now offers a case where we seem
not to have learned anything from oh
seven and no eight other foods for
thought legislation Constitution six
pages the bill establishing the Fed
twenty five pages the so2 the depart
related to cap and trade 15 pages
dodd-frank anybody 2,300 pages bigger
than the New Testament the Old Testament
and the Quran combined so you can govern
three major world religions in less
pages than you can to figure out
risk-based capital if somebody at my
University of Chicago class came up to
me and couldn't define swaps in a page I
would kindly suggest that maybe finance
was not something they should pursue
full-time the CFTC definition of a swap
is 865 pages google it it's a paragraph
two sentences 510
other food for thought are these great
crisises and markets to be served by
better rating agencies we have four
companies in the United States that have
a triple-a rating 14 in the world and
from 2000 to 2008 S&P and Moody's rated
17,000 securities triple-a is that the
solution or is it the problem where are
we going I think we're going next in
environmental markets away from the
United States I will honor mr. Chen
coming from Guangdong to this thing I
want I will say it wouldn't surprise me
if China beats us to a efficient
cap-and-trade market the Korean
legislature just passed 98% to start
cap-and-trade Vietnam floated it Kenya
is looking into it Mexico has won and
Brazil is starting one and India is
going to have 3 provincial so everybody
says cap-and-trade is dead it's only
dead in Washington DC and the
probability of these markets work is
inversely related to the distance from
Washington DC California is starting a
cap-and-trade and it'll be auctions in
October Europe it's working it's just
the United States political system is
broken and that is the difficulty with
cap-and-trade not the concept or its
efficient usage whether the next 40
years come and I'll finish with this I
think the next huge opportunity and the
next big problem is water ok that
basically water quality and water
quantity
and that we will see market-based
solutions to deal with the certification
and to deal with water quality problems
and there will be vast scales of
cap-and-trade in water not called
cap-and-trade called nutrient trading or
conservation credits or anything else
but the word cap-and-trade so this
legislation works I'm is optimistic over
the next 40 years that we're going to
develop markets that can deal with
social issues environmental issues and
that they will become routine and the US
will be a follower ultimately we will
get it because it's never good idea to
short the United States since
entrepreneurship its ability to rise so
I'm long term optimistic it's great to
be here with all of you you are the best
and brightest and it always puts a smile
on my face to come back to Yale to talk
about this subject thank you all very
much
I think I'm supposed to take questions
which I'm happy to do yes
I my own feeling in every market that
that I've been involved with whether
it's financial futures whether it's the
United States or the London exchange
financial futures or it says so - or
carbon there's four elements that you
have to deal with number one is
legislation for elements in the creation
of a new market
the second is regulation the third is
the institution building the exchange
and the fourth is the design of the
contract as Professor Koh says in the
introduction that development of new
markets is really very complex web of
educational needs so every time I've
developed a new market a first place I
went to the University because in my
opinion it takes 20 years so if I'm
talking to all of you in your 20s you'll
be corporate leaders 20 years from now
so it starts here markets 0 to 2 is
infancy 2 to 5 is teenager 5 to 10 is
young adult 10 to 20 is senior ok mature
adults so it's 20 years I don't know why
but they didn't use the personal
computer in journalism schools for five
six years after Steven Jobs invented it
power-steering was invented in the 1930s
didn't get used until the 50s the web
took 20 years after the personal
computer so you start with students then
you start with academics because you
want that to be taught by academics in
their curriculum then it's not foreign
when you see it use so it you build with
that
you have to educate the lawyers which is
one hell of a job and you've got to
educate the accountants then you've got
to educate the back offices of financial
institutions and then you have to do
management and an executive training and
educate CEOs and CFOs and hopefully
after you do that you build an exchange
which means you have to educate the
people in Washington it used to be now
you just have to lobby them not educate
them and it's not because they're bad
people it's just the system is that's
the way it works
you've got to educate the regulator
right you need to get the commissioners
on board of the regulatory agency and
very importantly you have to educate the
staff right then you have to educate
people who are futures brokers and
options brokers so they can go out and
sell a product and then last you have to
write a contract and a good contract a
good contract is one that either
everybody likes or nobody likes okay it
can't favor the buyer or the seller
everybody's got to walk away a little
hungry and say this is not perfect okay
and it's very important to recognize
when you're inventing a financial
instrument that perfection is the enemy
of good you kind of want to get it
Kumada sized but not perfectly so
because then somebody has an advantage
and it will be manipulated it's got to
be a little what we call English in it a
little spin to it
that's an art and I failed it a lot of
them like which I thought were good like
kilo gold I said everybody trades Key
Largo one we're gonna trade 100 ounces
this is in 1975 the world is behind
everybody deals in kilo bars well it
turns out I was behind it only had to be
a hundred ounces plus or minus five and
be shiny and three nines fine and you
could calculate the dollar value of it
easily
you couldn't educate kilos to
professional traders it was a pain in
the neck okay we trade cookie wheat in
Chicago cookie wheat is the benchmark
for worldwide wheat where bread wheat
well I said that's ridiculous how can
you be trading cookie wheat you should
trade bread wheat failed died on arrival
okay so what's obvious isn't necessarily
going to work it's a very long answer
but it's a very complex problem I hope I
got that across it's my walking around
bothering I'm Restless hello my name is
Pedro from School of Management
I wanted to ask you a little bit more
about the voluntary market you were
discussing with whether you had the
reductions of around 400 million tons of
emissions what what is the dollar value
of that market and and what are the
strategies for growing it it doesn't
exist anymore
in 2010 I sold the exchange to the
Intercontinental exchange and the pilot
ended and they did not extend it they
did extend the European climate exchange
which is now the largest market in the
world
they did extend the Tian Jing climate
exchange but the voluntary market I
think I it's hard for me to make
suppositions about why but it's clear
that Washington played a role in it and
the lack of prospects and when the towel
was thrown in two months after we sold
that I think they voted not to continue
the market another thing what else you
have to do which I didn't answer
you got a finance all of this right you
start in exchange you started a new
market you go through it we got started
by a grant from a foundation then I did
what most entrepreneurs did my knees are
bloodied from groveling for money we hit
friends and family and one thing which I
think you might find interesting
our first outside investor was the
Jesuits who put in 1.6 million dollars
in capital and those of you in
management who have been from the
business world this is like a Magritte
painting where fish fly and birds swim
when you talk to father Francis about
his investment in the Chicago climate
exchange my secretary would come in
hushed over and say it's father Francis
on the phone richer and I would pick up
the telephone and I would say hello
father
and he would say hello Richard and then
he would ask me something you would
never want a priest to ask you Richard
how is your burn rate it's not too good
father
you signing up any members no father are
the prospects good for legislation no
father and then he would end it as I've
never heard in 40 years an investor and
an enterprise ended a conversation and
he'd say I pray for you every night
Richard anyway father Francis came in at
about a half a pound or so I don't know
her pound we sold the company at seven
and a half pounds he made fifteen times
his money and it was the happiest day of
my life because I wanted to make sure
his client was well served and so the
financing is a big part of it as well
you've got to start a new business
straight people market choose an
electronic platform decide the bid-offer
spread the price increments and carbon
etc etc etc it's a lot of work ten years
go ahead hi my name is Anna and I'm from
this go ahead forestry and environmental
science hi Anna hello it's really
unfortunate that you're here today
because following this class we
following this talk in one of my classes
will be discussing an article by Larry
Loman titled carbon trading climate
justice and the production of ignorance
ten examples I don't know if you're
familiar with it you're actually quoted
in the arm of his reasons why he thinks
that open trading is not a viable means
of actually reducing co2 emissions for
reasons such as you know offsets not
really no one can quantify whether they
are equivalent to co2 emissions you know
if you emit in one area of the world and
somebody buys permits for reductions
from that area does it really have the
same effect yeah let me get into
some of this number one you saw offsets
are trivial okay and so everybody makes
only because it's good journal writing
it's good press you talk about not
really sweating there's something
perverse I find with a certain set of
environmentalists who think that you're
not doing good unless you have pain okay
you need to suffer to be doing good and
offsets isn't a suffering thing it's an
easier solution I just don't buy it I
think that these people are gonna the
same people who talked about how
automobiles would never work horses were
better that the personal computer wasn't
necessary there's no economic role for
it I think it's such a yesterday
argument when everybody who is bright in
China and India and Brazil the countries
that are growing enormous Lee are
experimenting with cap and trade and yet
our journalists and a lot of our
academics of debunking it so I'd love to
be here because I I think it's absurd on
its face one of the other points was
that carbon trade might stymie
technological innovation what what do
you think regards to that do you think
pricing somebody what did we talk of
people in India Isaac Bruce Ain you want
to know what something is worth it Spurs
innovation you know that kind of
argument says we don't want to know the
price of anything right when economists
spend most of it how I'm trying to
figure out price because it's such a
pregnant signal you know the problem is
and it's what killed cap and trade in
the United States is people forget when
Napoleon called in his generals after an
unsuccessful
battle he said when I said take Vienna I
meant take Vienna the implication was I
did intend you to go to the suburbs
I'd intend you to go to Salzburg the
military objective is to do this by and
large very often the principle objective
gets added on to in Washington DC so we
forget that that the climate bill was
meant to reduce co2 emissions it had
1500 pages of goodies and built-in
arbitrage is because somebody said
there's no justice and I was actually in
a meeting and I said I think we're here
to reduce climate change I'm afraid of
it for my kids and my grandkids and they
said no no no we're here about justice
and I said I must be at the wrong
meeting you can take care of justice on
Sunday in your church and you can deal
with the moral implications I thought
we're here to to stop desertification
and stop climate change and stop the
clay no no so you get a hundred
sub-goals built into a piece of
legislation because you have to get
buy-in not because these are bad people
it's just the way it works when I was
dealing with a person in Washington on
the hill whose name shall not be
mentioned and I said to their chief of
staff I'd like to come in to DC to tell
you about the Chicago climate exchange
what we got right and what we got wrong
how much it cost to monitor how did we
do with it how did we verify all of
those things and the response was we
don't talk to anybody until after we
write the bill
and I said this is the dumbest thing I
have ever heard and then a week later I
said that's the smartest thing I've ever
heard because they're right because if
you do it that way you maximize campaign
contributions right because you create
problems that have to be fixed and if
they have to be fixed you have lobbyists
lawyers etc so the initial piece of
legislation just is a viewpoint it's not
meant to solve a problem because you
don't maximize the income or reelection
probabilities by getting it right at the
outset which is and again not because
these are bad folks
it's just the way DC works Washington DC
just surpassed Silicon Valley in the
highest per capita income in the United
States it doesn't produce anything but
laws and regulations
just working Tyler Van Leeuwen from the
School of Management so to follow up on
your point there you know if the
government is gonna be involved in
crafting some kind of climate
legislation in the US you seem to think
it's gonna be cap-and-trade do you have
any faith and their ability to do that
well and to create a market that would
have your good derivatives as opposed to
something that's a failure not now five
years from now yes but not now it will
take the Chinese to do it successfully
in the Indians to do it successfully we
will be unfortunately we are a laggard
you know when it comes to these issues
well it happened eventually yeah because
I'm from Chicago and we wrote it off
this the Rust Belt in 1990 it's never
been more vibrant this this country you
the bright young people I've been
talking to and will be talking to I'm
going to West Point and talk to cadets
4,000 of them on Thursday if onto your
sister schools and and around the world
and every time I walk out of an
experience like this I get optimistic
because you have table rasa's the the
slate is pretty clean and it's your
country and I think the young people
will not be put aside eventually now yes
but over the long term no so the answer
is maybe 2017 to 2020 in the United
States 2015 in China 2013 maybe actually
two provinces mr. Chen is here from one
of them Guangdong and who obey our
starting pilots Shanghai began two
months ago and one don't just began
yeah three cities have begun so I I
don't look to Washington DC I look to
Beijing I don't look to Washington I
look to Delhi I don't look to Washington
I look to Sacramento study those markets
there's career opportunities here watch
what's going on in the environment
outside the United States for the
solvers and the question is how do you
get a standard so let me kind of talk to
that for a second because we argue and
have argued for the last 15 years it
won't be Kyoto okay he will be a plural
lateral regimes in different countries
linked with certain same instruments and
it will develop like the cotton market
developed with a center in in Mumbai a
center in Alexandria Egypt the center
and Winterthur a center in Liverpool and
they will evolve into a worldwide
homogeneous commodity it won't come from
one top-down fix it will follow the
pattern of commodity development and if
you look at grain trade the Board of
Trade invented grain standards it took
till 1910 from 1848 before the US
government adopted those so they were
proved and tried in private sector and
then ratified by the government so I
would expect that to happen we will have
I think centers in Europe will have one
in North America will likely have one in
South America one in China one in India
probably one in Japan and Australia New
Zealand small markets there
thank you dr. sander for a terrific talk
what you just said actually inspired a
new question than the one I've been
dying to ask you so I'll just split it
out you in the beginning of your talk
you said that an aspect of a good
derivative is price discovery and
transparency and what you just described
is a fragmented system of different
centers of trade and so I'm wondering
how do you see that path towards price
transparency to give you a little
background I have my my previous life
before I was an academic I was in the
carbon market and that lack of price
transparency really made things tough
yeah it was it was tough because it was
an over-the-counter market and if we go
back look no exchange failed in no seven
oh eight or nine not the London Stock
Exchange not the Paris bourse not any
derivatives exchange 78 of them in 36
countries had the chicago model and they
all worked and they were all transparent
they were all regulated and I think it
will evolve to regulated transparent
markets I think the danger the toxicity
comes from opaqueness and no regulation
we did something very different I called
up Mary Schapiro who was then in charge
of FINRA Mary was a CFTC commissioner
and I knew her and I said Mary I'm going
to ask you to do something that you
probably will be very surprised that and
she said what's that I said I want to be
regulated we're exempt okay because I
don't want this to be viewed as the
Chicago thing
Ford's data's phony we want to print the
prices we want to do that and the
problem in O 7 and O eight and in the
carbon market outside of the
European carbon market and our carbon
market is they were pink and this is
where the problems come they weren't
regulated they weren't centrally cleared
you know we're curing some of it with
dodd-frank but not all of it it's a
really easy fix the problem is the
process that you go through in
legislation is designed to create
regulatory or tax arbitrage ha's right
because you solve half of the problem
but the result is it throws another
problem or if you smart another
financial opportunity right in your face
and this is the difficulty brings me to
my original question for you which is
that your critics say that you know the
the unexpected unprecedented success of
the of the CCX the popularity with
industry cetera was due to very lenient
baselines and low additionality
standards and your proponents say hey
this was a pilot program you were
proving that something could work you
needed industrial buy-in and so I'm
wondering now that you've worked on so
many exchanges how do you view that
trade-off between environmental
integrity and industrial usability well
part of it was meant to show what a it
was by the way inaccurately it wasn't
lacks it was the same reductions that
was in McCain Lieberman and
waxman-markey so if you extended we had
a six percent cut for seven years and if
it would have gone on it would have been
the same reduction all of the federal
legislation so that's just fact
- I'm driven buying all of you going
into this it's a good message here to
look at at the way things develop and
that is don't go for perfection okay I
mean it is not the idea the idea is to
get it off the ground we never use the
word failure at CCX or any other company
I've run these are trials okay there's a
drug called Salveson 6:06 19th century
developed by email' Airlink it was to
deal with venereal diseases at the time
you know why it's called six oh six he
got it wrong six hundred and five times
okay
please be guided of not seeking
perfection or fear of failing that my
particular approach is to people is just
get it going just start the Wright
brothers flew for 90 seconds at 60 feet
high they didn't have seatbelts okay
they had nothing in a trial and when
you're inventing and Steven jobs first
PC I did a PhD in 1966 a thousand years
ago in the Jurassic era this thing has
got more power than the IBM 1620 I'd lug
around batch processing cards I mean we
demand perfection and environment when
we don't demand it medically
technologically industrially in any
field of inventive activity we accept
that the first model is not going to be
perfect we seem to falsely demand that
the environment has to be perfect you
just need to clean up a bunch of water
you need to clean up a bunch of so2 you
need to clean up a bunch of arse thick
you need to get these programs going and
then you can always
and perfect and I think to all of you
were going to go out and your careers
and want no don't please these are
trials don't look for perfection you're
gonna get disappointed and some of the
greatest inventions we've ever had that
have saved lives never started without
its critics because if you're doing
something you're an agent of change I
was pretty comfortable in CCX because
the right-wing hated us because they
thought we were a bunch of
environmentalists and the left-wing
hated us because they thought we were a
bunch of capitalists and I thought this
is good you know it's where I want to be
because if you're gonna do something
disruptive you're gonna by definition
gouging establishment and it's pretty ah
high that most people with any new
product are not going to like you you
can imagine going to wall street in 1972
and saying I'm from Chicago and I'm here
to narrow your spreads okay this is what
I'd like to do I want to take all those
opaque market you working on and I want
to make them public they said why don't
you go back to Berkeley you know and
teaching that suits you well the capital
markets aren't for you so if you're
going to be involved in something
disruptive don't expect the
establishment to be pleased and if they
are pleased you got to question your
premises you know you want to be
disruptive
I think I'm happy to go on but I think
that I'm seeing a signal here that it's
time to to get everything let me just
say to you you know again Yale never
disappoints you are the best and the
brightest we do need
people doing regulated transparent
markets we need a lot of faith in using
these markets we just have to police
them derivatives are like hammers okay
you can use it to go bash somebody's
head in or you can use it to build the
house so go build houses thank you